quatre ans après sa disparition les
enquêteurs chargés de l'affairé stèle
mouzin sur sa famille qu'il ne relâchent
pas leurs efforts après avoir écarté une
application de michel fourniret dans la
disparition de la fillette il
s'intéresse à une autre tentative
d'enlèvement qui pourrait les mener sur
la piste du ravisseurs de la petite
estelle yves castel edouard da costa
elle aurait 13 ans mais est elle a
disparu le 9 janvier 2003 la sortie de
son école
une disparition sans témoin sans un vis
comme un mystère avec un père qui depuis
quatre ans se demande comment sa fille a
pu se volatiliser
un soir de janvier pour les gens qui
sont étrangers au domaine judiciaire
c'est extrêmement dur de savoir comment
progresse l'enquète il faudrait savoir
cela fait pourtant quatre ans qu ici à
versailles
neuf enquêteurs travaillent
quotidiennement sur le dossier estelle
mouzin 4500 procès verbaux rédigés 150
gardes à vue 400 perquisition tous les
milieux pédophiles écumé sans aucun
résultat
et puis il ya eu l'ombre de michel
fourniret qui a plané sur la sphère et
si le tueur en série était également le
prédateur des stèles une fausse piste
conclu aujourd'hui ensemble procureurs
et enquêteurs
aujourd'hui rien directement ou
indirectement ne le rattache à l'
enquête sur la disparition d'estelle
mais il y a encore des vérifications à
faire michel fourniret n'est pas encore
totalement sorti du dossier les
enquêteurs ont donc retourné en belgique
à la fin du mois pour écarter
définitivement la piste fourniret
mais aussi pour en explorer une autre ce
portrait robot du ravisseur présumé
d'estelle mouzin aurait été reconnu par
une fillette victime d'une tentative
d'enlèvement dans le sud du pays le
véhicule utilisé était dans son cas
aussi une cabane est blanche
c'est au travers de d'autres tentatives
qui concerne d'autres jeunes filles
qu'on pourra se rapprocher de celui qui
a commis l'enlèvement des stèles et ce
n'est certainement pas un fait isolé et
s'il existe des faits similaires en
belgique
fait qu'ils peuvent se rapprocher de la
disparition d'estelle c'est évidemment
impératif donc été dessus ça permettra
peut-être de trouver enfin la piste
recherchaient quatre ans plus tard c'est
ce qu'espère toujours les parents
d'estelle mouzin